a 90-day National Health Emergency in
Peruan Ecuador as migratory birds from
North America bring with them the highly
contagious avian or bird flu they've
been infecting wild birds on their path
towards the southern continent the
threat became clear after birds were
found dead along Peru's northern coast
at least 13 000 of them say
environmental authorities mostly
Pelicans
the outbreak reached a poultry farm in
Northern Lima where perus agricultural
Health Services nearly 37 000 birds were
slaughtered this week to control the
spread but in Ecuador it was much worse
the government says at least 180 000
birds will have to be called to protect
the poultry sector which generates 23
percent of Ecuador's agricultural GDP
this outbreak is contained all Protocols
are being applied so that it does not
spread in the five kilometer buffer zone
there are no more contaminated Farms
commercial producers in both countries
say they have taken strict measures to
secure their Farm perimeters Peru's
government has banned live bird markets
the industry accounts for two percent of
its GDP and it's the most consumed
protein among low income peruvians
the worst thing that can happen is that
this spreads to commercial Farms if
chickens and hens die chicken prices
will Skyrocket and it will no longer be
a health but a famine issue
Health officials say the h5n1avian flu
strain found in Peru could infect humans
through close contact
officials say the transmission of this
virus among humans is very rare but
they're worried because the summer
season here is about to begin and
they're urging people who are already
coming to the beach to stay away from
any dead birds
concerned Neighbors at puntarmosa beach
south of Lima say the stench of dead
birds is too close
we've called different entities to come
and clean up they came one day and took
some dead birds and never came back
people come and try and see the birds
and we want to prevent this from
happening too
authorities here and in Ecuador say they
are working fast to contain the outbreak
a silent epidemic but with no treatment
or cure death is assured for these birds
reaching ashore for a time to rest their
beak but yeah Lima Peru